and finally new rule republicans can't
spend decades chastising liberals for
being too permissive about sex and drugs
and then be completely silent about matt
gates
i
i don't know if you've been following
the whole matt gates saga but he's the
republican congressman from florida
who always looks like he's saying eat it
nerd
and who has been embroiled in a sex and
drug scandal the last two months
here's cnn on a night out with matt
gates
the party-goers at times dressed in
formal wear from a political event
a political event they just left mingled
and shared drugs like cocaine and
ecstasy
some had sex okay wild hotel sweet
parties
that's our thing
democrats are the party of free love and
fun
and forgetting where you parked your car
republicans
cannot be the conservative stick up your
ass party and then take our drugs and
[ __ ] our women
american government works best like a
mullet republicans do business in the
front
democrats party in the back
jfk used to have nude pool parties in
the white house
now the politician who comes closest to
carrying on that legacy
is matt gates no
and he's not the only one former house
speaker and a guy who loved his
liquor john boehner now sells
pot for a living
my old job
marjorie taylor greene is reportedly
into polyamorous tantric sex
and ashley babbitt the maga warrior who
died storming the capital turns out to
have been in a throuple
with her husband and another woman and
don't get me started on this guy
even their spiritual advisors are freaks
jerry falwell
jr apparently likes to relax after a
hard day at bible college by watching
the pool boy
do the misses i know republicans are
lazy and they love outsourcing but come
on
and here he is on a yacht proudly posing
with a friend
with their pants unzipped
not some friend this is a long way
from when his father made a national
issue that one of the teletubbies was
purple
so doug gay
what happened republicans republicans
always sounded like this
now because politico did an expose on
his lap dance with the naked lady in a
strip club
he's not the kind of person you can ask
your sister to vote for anymore
naked lady laptop sister that's the
republican
party i know so uptight they could grind
diamonds in their ass
while liberals used our asses the way
god intended to smuggle drugs
you could always count on republicans to
be the fuddy duddies the wet blankets
the boars they were the moral majority
the book of virtues nixon
nixon started the war on drugs and this
lady never stopped spitting her
catchphrase about it
just say no just say no just say no just
say no
just say no just say no just say no
[Applause]
her husband had a commission to root out
pornography
if it was fun republicans were against
it they got apoplectic
over clinton getting a blow job they
invented
abstinence-only education mitt romney
has never seen himself naked
[Applause]
john ashcroft i'm not kidding once
covered the tits
on a statue
rick santorum wears a sweater vest
newt gingrich once said quote democrats
were the party of total hedonism total
exhibitionism total bizarreness
total weirdness well on a good night i
suppose
and frankly newt knowing that you
believe what i did on an average friday
night was morally reprehensible
just made it all the more fun
we need to restore the natural order of
things i don't want to live in a world
where liberals are the uptight ones and
conservatives do drugs and get laid
once upon a time the right were the ones
offended by everything they were the
party of speech codes and blacklists and
moral panics
and demanding some tv show had to go
well now that's us we're the fun suckers
now
we suck the fun out of everything
halloween
the oscars childhood twitter comedy
it's like woke kids on campus decided to
be all the worst parts of a southern
baptist
and that's wrong because it's cultural
appropriation
if democrats had always policed morality
as hard as they do now they would be
down
a lot of heroes no fdr
jfk rfk lbj
clinton martin luther king democrats are
now the party that can't tell the
difference between anthony weiner and al
franken
or
katie hill up and coming democratic
congresswoman from california now
resigned
who like ashley babbitt was found to be
in a throuple
and pictured holding a bong and that was
too much for our new puritanical
democratic party
quite the opposite this should be our
logo
[Applause]
we're the thrupal people the bong people
the tantric sex gurus not
[ __ ] matt gates us we did [ __ ] in
the mud and bra burning and turn on and
tune in and drop out
they're the party who won't bake wedding
cakes for gay people
it's time to switch back because frankly
you're not good at being us and being
you sucks
you